Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Cette vidéo a été tournée
par les caméras de surveillance
d’un site minier au Brésil.
Un barrage qui contenait les résidus
d’exploitation d’une mine de fer
sous forme de boues,
a cédé en janvier 2019.
Il y a eu 272 morts et des dégâts
environnementaux et matériels énormes.
Cette deuxième vidéo a été tournée
au Canada.
En 2014,
un barrage qui contenait les déchets d’une
mine d’or et de cuivre s’est effondré.
Il n’y a pas eu de victimes
humaines directes,
mais les dégâts sur l’environnement
furent énormes, là aussi.
Peut-être connaissez-vous ces images,
elles ont fait le tour du monde.
Difficile de ne pas être
touché et interpellé.
Je travaille dans le secteur minier
et on s’est dit qu’il y avait urgence
à trouver des solutions.
La première solution qui vient à l’esprit
de beaucoup de monde, la plus facile,
c’est : « OK, on pourrait arrêter
toute activité industrielle. »
Mais nous sommes tous des consommateurs
de produits industriels.
Pratiquement tout le monde parmi vous
a dans sa poche un smartphone,
à la maison, une télé, des ordinateurs,
un beau set de cuisine,
mais aussi des couverts en acier inox.
Pour fabriquer tout ça,
il nous faut des métaux.
Et les métaux viennent de la terre,
du minerai qu’il faut extraire
et transformer.
Vous voyez, on est tous concernés.
Je travaille en Nouvelle-Calédonie pour
un industriel du nickel depuis quinze ans.
Ça me permet de vivre
cette réalité au quotidien.
Je m’occupe actuellement du processus
d’asséchement des résidus.
Je suis conscient des problématiques
et je veux améliorer la situation.
Ça fait des années que
je cherche des solutions
comme d’autres qui travaillent
dans ce secteur.
Et au fur et à mesure qu’on en trouve,
on en applique certaines
pour faire évoluer les choses.
La Nouvelle-Calédonie possède
des paysages, une nature, une flore
et une faune extraordinaires.
Elle possède aussi
des ressources minières incroyables.
On a là un sacré mélange,
donc le maintien de l’équilibre mérite
des efforts et des investissements.
On a essayé pendant longtemps
de trouver une solution
qui permettrait de sauvegarder
l’environnement,
et aussi d’éviter le genre de catastrophes
que je vous ai montrées en vidéo.
Comment les innovations technologiques
peuvent nous aider dans tout ça ?
Pour extraire les métaux du minerai,
les deux processus principaux
sont la pyro-métallurgie,
qui fait fondre les métaux contenus
dans le minerai
et qui génère des résidus solides -
les scories -
et l’hydro-métallurgie.
Elle utilise l'acide pour séparer
les métaux du minerai.
Elle consomme sept fois moins
d’électricité,
mais elle génère une quantité importante
de résidus sous forme de boues.
Partout dans le monde, on utilise
des barrages pour stocker ces résidus
en attendant que la partie liquide
des boues soit récupérée
ou qu’elle s’évapore.
Une autre façon de stocker
les résidus, moins connue,
mais très utilisée dans des pays
comme l’Indonésie,
la Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée,
les Philippines
et en Europe aussi,
s’appelle « deep-sea tailing »,
ou résidus en eaux profondes.
Avec cette méthode très peu coûteuse,
les boues sont tout simplement déchargées
en profondeur dans l’océan,
sans aucun traitement.
C’est très moche,
on est d’accord.
Soyons honnêtes, un industriel
ne fait pas ses choix
et ne prend pas ses décisions en se basant
simplement sur l’écologie.
C’est la réglementation stricte
et les pressions justifiées
venant de différentes organisations,
et de l’opinion publique aussi,
qui poussent les industriels
à avoir des comportements
de plus en plus respectueux
de l’environnement
et donc à chercher de nouvelles solutions.
Et c'est tant mieux.
C’est une très bonne nouvelle,
car l’enjeu, évidemment, c’est arriver
à stocker les résidus miniers
de façon stable, sécuritaire
et la plus écologique possible.
Et nous avons réussi à relever ce défi.
Tout le processus s’appuie sur
des machines très puissantes
qu’on appelle des filtres-presses.
Ces filtres-presses sont utilisés
depuis longtemps,
mais jamais pour les rejets
de l’industrie du nickel.
Clairement, c’est une innovation,
car à chaque déchet, il nous faut
trouver sa recette spéciale.
Voici celle des résidus liquides
miniers de Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Je vous explique.
On reçoit de l’usine des boues
assez liquides
et ces boues, on doit les épaissir
avant de les filtrer.
Pour ça, on les traite
avec un épaississeur.
Une fois qu’on les a concentrées
au fond de l’épaississeur,
on les transfère avec une pompe
dans la cuve qui est chargée
d’alimenter les filtres-presses.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi,
ça me rappelle du chocolat.
C'est excellent pour notre recette.
Le filtre-presse est une machine composée
de plusieurs plaques en plastique.
Sur les deux surfaces de ces plaques,
on pose les toiles de filtration.
Elles sont chargées de laisser
passer le liquide
et retenir les solides
à l’intérieur des chambres.
Sur la surface de la moitié
des plaques du filtre,
on pose aussi des membranes gonflables,
une sorte de grande chambre à air,
tandis que la surface
de l’autre moitié de plaque
est creusée de façon à créer
un espace vide qu’on appelle chambre.
Allez, on y va !
Le filtre-presse se referme.
Mais, avec l’aide de la tête mobile,
on va bien serrer entre les plaques,
comme ça, nos chambres désormais étanches
et avec leur toile,
sont prêtes à recevoir
nos boues bien épaisses.
Et là, les solides restent piégés
par les toiles de filtration
et seulement la partie liquide
peut en sortir.
On appelle ça le filtre.
Là, vous voyez comme c’est clair
et vraiment différent du chocolat
qu’on avait au début.
Une fois qu’on a rempli nos chambres,
la plupart de l’eau est partie,
on s’est dit : « Pour chasser
encore plus d’eau,
pourquoi pas gonfler nos membranes ? »
Mais oui.
Très bonne idée.
Cela nous permet de presser
le contenu des chambres,
mais surtout, ça élimine la plupart
de l’eau qui est encore restée.
Et ça, c'est le résultat qu'on recherche.
De l'air comprimé envoyé dans le système
de façon à traverser le gâteau.
Gâteau ?
Oui, c’est comme ça que dans le métier,
on appelle le produit final
de la filtration.
Ce soufflage sert à chasser l’humidité.
Voilà, pour terminer, il ne reste
qu’à dégonfler les membranes
et à ouvrir le filtre.
Les volets du bac placés
sous le filtre s’ouvrent
et avec la séparation des plaques,
notre gâteau compact,
mais surtout bien sec,
peut tomber en contrebas,
dans l’espace sous le filtre.
Là, il va être collecté et transporté
dans l’endroit de stockage.
Bon appétit !
il ne reste plus qu’à faire la vaisselle.
Ça veut dire rincer à grande eau
les toiles de filtration
et refermer le filtre qui sera prêt
pour les cycles suivants,
car il doit assurer
ses 3 000 tonnes de gâteaux
produites par jour et par filtre.
Voilà, on vient de récupérer
75 % de l’eau de nos boues
qui sera réutilisée par la suite
et on sait combien la gestion
des eaux est importante.
Tout cela peut sembler simple, facile,
mais réaliser, exécuter tout ce processus
a demandé des années
de recherches au constructeur.
Beaucoup de travail, de mise au point
et des tonnes de matière grise.
Les résultats sont là et nous récompensent
de tous les efforts.
Les résidus asséchés seront stockés,
et cela, sans contrainte de barrages
ou de protection particulière,
car ils sont inertes,
comme un gros tas de terre.
Des tests ont déjà été effectués
concernant la possibilité
de revégétaliser ce résidu
avec des plantes endémiques
du maquis minier calédonien.
Les résultats sont très encourageants,
comme on peut voir sur ces photos.
D’une part, car sur cette parcelle,
les seules plantes apportées par nos soins
sont celles que vous voyez
sur la photo de gauche
Et d’autre part, car le maquis minier
pousse très lentement.
L’industrie n’est pas qu’une entité
abstraite, sale, froide.
L’industrie, ce sont des personnes
qui sont là pour la faire fonctionner.
J'en fais partie.
Mais ici, parmi nous, on a peut-être
les ingénieurs, les techniciens de demain,
ces jeunes, ces enfants qui travailleront
dans cette future industrie
et on a tous intérêt
à ce qu’elle soit performante,
mais surtout concernée
par la sauvegarde de l’environnement.
À moins d’un bouleversement total
de notre modèle économique,
nous sommes dépendants des industries.
Elles ne s'arrêteront pas
du jour au lendemain.
Mais le défi de protéger notre planète
est crucial et urgent.
Nous, les vieux, issus d’un monde
de dinosaures, on fait de notre mieux.
Ce sont les jeunes qui pourront
nous aider à mieux gérer
les déchets des industries.
Tout doit être réuni pour réussir :
des idées,
de l’engagement, des esprits
brillants et vifs.
Peut-être vous ou vos enfants.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)